Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Qu’est-ce que c’est qu’une odeur ?
Une odeur, c’est un bouquet
de petites molécules
qu’on appelle des composés
organiques volatils,
des COV.
Les COV, il y en a partout.
Ils vous entourent tous les jours ;
ils vont influencer vos comportements.
Ils vont provoquer de l'attraction,
de la répulsion.
C’est pour ça que vous allez mettre
du déodorant et du parfum
le matin par exemple,
pour attirer ou ne pas repousser,
ça dépend.
L’odeur, ce n’est pas seulement
des cellules olfactives dans le nez.
C'est aussi plein d'émotions,
plein de souvenirs.
C'est aussi des comportements réflexes.
Par exemple, si, là,
je vous dis que ça sent une bonne
odeur de gâteau au chocolat
ou de tarte aux pommes,
vous l’imaginez cette odeur.
Sans doute que vous allez avoir faim
et aussi vous sentir bien.
À l’inverse, si vous passez
devant des toilettes publiques
qui n’ont pas été lavées
depuis plusieurs jours,
instinctivement, vous allez vous
mettre en rétention urinaire.
Donc l’odeur, c’est ça.
C'est aussi plein d'émotions et des
émotions individuelles, culturelles.
Si là et je vous demande à tous
de vous concentrer sur vous
et de penser à une odeur de votre
enfance - douce, sécurisante, apaisante.
Allez-y, essayez.
Vous allez voir, ça va venir très vite.
Vous allez sentir cette odeur,
Cette odeur, elle appartient
à chacun d’entre vous.
C'est votre souvenir.
Moi je suis infirmière, ou plutôt
infirmière-chercheur à l’Institut Curie.
Je m’occupe des plaies
complexes liés au cancer.
C’est-à-dire que la tumeur,
malheureusement,
au lieu d’être à l’intérieur du corps
et de ne pas être vue,
elle va s’extérioriser à la peau.
Je vous rassure, c’est rare,
et des équipes comme la mienne
s’en occupent tous les jours.
Ces plaies ont une particularité :
elles sentent mauvais.
Non pas parce que le patient est sale,
non pas parce qu’il s’est mal lavé,
mais parce que dans cette plaie
qui est une masse, une tumeur,
il y a des bactéries qui vont émettre ces
fameuses petites molécules, ces COV,
qui auront une odeur similaire à celle
des cadavres en voie de décomposition.
Que se passe-t-il pour l’entourage,
pour celui qui croise ce patient,
pour le soignant qui vient ?
Il va sentir cette odeur et de façon
réflexe, il va penser à la mort
et il va avoir tendance
à rester moins longtemps,
à repartir, à trouver une excuse.
Et nos patients, à des moments de la vie
où ils sont évidemment vulnérables,
où ils sont fragiles,
où ils auraient besoin de notre affection
et de notre entourage,
eh bien au contraire,
ils vont être rejetés.
C’est ce qui nous a donné envie
de travailler sur ces odeurs
pour trouver des nouvelles
solutions anti-odeurs.
Je dis « nous » parce qu’en recherche,
on ne travaille jamais seul,
on travaille toujours ensemble.
On a travaillé, et quatre ans après,
on a breveté un nouveau pansement
anti-odeurs à base de cannelle.
Comme ça, ça peut paraître simple -
c’est toujours simple
quand on est à la fin de l’histoire -
mais pour réussir
à développer ce pansement,
il a fallu qu’on étudie les odeurs
de ces plaies, les odeurs de cette tumeur.
On a fait donc de la microbiologie,
de l’étude des bactéries,
parce que c’est ce qui va relarguer
le plus ces petites molécules.
On a fait aussi de la chromatographie
où on a analysé chaque pic d’odeur.
Après, on a relié ces pics
d’odeur aux bactéries.
Comme vous le voyez sur ce schéma -
un chromatographe -
on a essayé de voir
quelle bactérie émettait quelle odeur.
Après ce gros travail, on s'est
retrouvé avec quelques COV.
On ne savait pas pourquoi.
Ils ne semblaient pas émis par des
bactéries, ni par les pansements,
ni par la personne elle-même -
parce qu’on a chacun
notre odeur individuelle -
ni par de l’alimentation
que le patient aurait prise.
Et de fil en aiguille,
on a émis l’hypothèse
que peut-être c’était la tumeur
qui avait elle-même émis ces COV.
Très bien.
Mais si cette plaie tumorale
émet des COV, peut-être que la tumeur,
quand elle est à l’intérieur du corps,
quand elle est toute petite,
elle émet déjà des COV.
Et si c’est le cas, peut-être que ces
COV pourraient nous permettre
de faire un diagnostic du cancer
précoce par les odeurs.
Mais comment on peut faire ?
Comment on pourrait détecter ces odeurs ?
Soit en poursuivant
de la chimie analytique,
mais attention, ce n’est pas
aussi simple que sur ce schéma.
Parce que l’odeur humaine,
elle est extrêmement complexe.
Elle est variable dans le temps, avec les
hormones, avec ce que vous mangez,
avec votre environnement,
avec votre évolution propre.
Soit, peut-être, en utilisant un super nez
qui détecte déjà
dans la vie de tous les jours
des drogues, des explosifs,
du pétrole, de l’argent,
c’est-à-dire le chien.
Et le chien, il y en a beaucoup
et il y en a partout.
Donc peut-être,
et je dis bien « peut-être »,
que le chien pourrait détecter
précocement le cancer
dans des pays à faible accès aux soins.
On n’a pas accès, par exemple, pour les
femmes facilement à la mammographie.
Je ne dis pas qu’il remplacerait
la mammographie.
Quand on a un cancer,
il faut voir où est la tumeur,
s’il y en a plusieurs, faire une biopsie
pour adapter le traitement.
Mais peut-être qu’il pourrait
servir avant de pré-test
pour justement identifier les femmes qui
doivent aller passer une mammographie.
C’était une idée complètement
dingue en 2012,
qui rejoignait quand même
des auteurs de publications scientifiques.
Il y en avait notamment une qui avait
particulièrement attiré mon attention.
C’était un dermatologue qui avait publié
dans la fameuse revue The Lancet
en disant que plusieurs de ses patients
étaient venus au fil des années,
car leur chien avait
changé de comportement -
il n’arrêtait pas de les renifler.
Finalement il avait découvert
des mélanomes
et il émettait l’hypothèse que peut-être
le chien avait sniffé l’odeur du cancer.
C’est comme ça qu’est né le projet KDOG.
Je ne dis pas que
les débuts ont été faciles.
J’étais infirmière, une femme,
pas très grande en plus,
et je voulais détecter précocement
les cancers du sein avec des chiens.
Ok.
Le jour du lancement de projet,
Le Monde a écrit un article
pour annoncer ce lancement
puisque je cherchais des fonds.
Malheureusement,
c’est tombé le 1ᵉʳ avril 2016
(Rires)
et ça m’a valu le surnom du
« Poisson d’avril de l’Institut Curie ».
Rassurez-vous, ça ne m’a pas stressée,
ni empêchée de dormir
parce au contraire,
ça m’a fait une pub inespérée
et ça m’a permis de lever
des fonds pour démarrer le projet.
Très bien ; il y avait l’idée, les fonds,
mais après, il y avait tout à construire.
Travailler par exemple avec des cynos.
Les cynos - cynophiles -
c’est comme ça qu'on nomme
ceux qui éduquent
les chiens à la détection.
Évidemment, ce sont des professionnels
qui ne sont pas habitués
à faire de la recherche.
Il fallait créer la salle,
des cônes dans lesquels
allaient renifler les chiens,
et puis, bien sûr, construire
le programme scientifique
pour répondre à cette 1e question :
est-ce que les chiens en sont capables ?
On a fait assez simple.
On a demandé
à des volontaires saines, sans cancer,
et à des femmes à qui on venait
de diagnostiquer un cancer du sein,
de dormir une nuit avec
des compresses sur les seins.
Ces compresses se sont
imprégnées de sueur.
On a mis ces compresses dans des bocaux
qu’on a présentés aux chiens.
Il n’y a pas de contact direct
entre le chien et la personne.
On a éduqué deux malinois, Thor et Nikios,
à essayer de reconnaître
l’odeur du cancer du sein.
C’est comme sur la diapositive
que vous avez devant vous,
ils ont quatre cônes d’olfaction,
derrière les bocaux sont clipés
et on va les éduquer selon une méthode
de conditionnement positive.
C’est-à-dire que si le chien y arrive,
s’il s’assoit devant le bon cône,
il va être récompensé avec une croquette,
un jeu, un bout de saucisse.
S’il ne réussit pas,
il ne va pas être puni,
mais il ne va pas être récompensé.
Mais finalement,
cette motivation de la récompense
est bien plus forte
que la punition et la contrainte.
C’est valable pour l’homme,
c’est valable pour le chien.
Après six mois d’éducation intensive,
on est arrivé avec plus de
100 prélèvements dont 31 positifs.
Le cyno ne savait pas où étaient les
prélèvements positifs, le chien non plus,
et on a regardé ce qui se passait.
Les chiens ont trouvé les prélèvements
positifs dans plus de 90% des cas.
C'était vraiment une super nouvelle.
On était très très très contents
et on a bien fêté ça.
Mais ce n’était qu’une 1e étape.
C’est ce qu’on appelle des bons
résultats d’études préliminaires,
parce que ça ne ressemble
en rien à la vie.
Il fallait répondre à une autre question :
est-ce que les chiens en sont capables
sur une longue période,
qu’il fasse chaud, qu’il fasse froid,
et quand il y a beaucoup
de prélèvements négatifs
comme dans une vie réelle ?
Et dans notre étude préliminaire,
sur nos quatre cônes,
on avait toujours un positif,
trois négatifs.
C’est-à-dire qu’il y allait
à avoir souvent des lignes
où il n’y aurait que des négatifs.
Et est-ce que le chien serait capable
de dire « Il n’y a rien » ?
Ce sont des chiens de détection,
ce qu’ils aiment, c’est détecter.
Dire « il n’y a rien », c’est compliqué.
Pourquoi c'est compliqué ?
Tout simplement parce qu’il a peur
de ne pas avoir son bout de saucisse.
Donc on a préparé le protocole
de cette étude plus longue.
Avoir une vue sur la longueur,
c’est extrêmement important
en recherche clinique.
On s’est associé à d’autres hôpitaux
de manière à avoir des personnes
qui arrivent d’environnements différents.
Il y a sept hôpitaux qui ont participé,
qui se sont mis en marche
pour participer à cette étude.
On a fait autre chose.
On s’est dit : « On ne peut pas
continuer d’éduquer des chiens
sans savoir ce qu’ils sniffent.
Il faut refaire de la chimie analytique. »
Comme je l’ai dit,
c’est extrêmement complexe.
Ça utilise des machines
extrêmement puissantes
et il faut vraiment bien
connaître l’odeur humaine.
Donc on s’est associé avec
ceux qui sont les meilleurs
pour la recherche sur la personne humaine,
c’est-à-dire l’IRCGN,
l’Institut de recherche criminelle
de la Gendarmerie nationale.
C’est ceux que vous connaissez
tous plus simplement
sous le nom des experts
de la police scientifique,
ceux qu’on voit dans les films,
par exemple.
On a fait une troisième chose,
puisque les années avaient passé,
d’autres équipes travaillaient
sur tout type de cancer dans le monde.
On s’est dit qu’on allait tous les réunir
à Paris autour de KDOG International
pour échanger parce que quand même,
on avait plein de questions.
On se disait :
« Est-ce qu’on va dans le bon sens ? »
Dans ce cas-là, c’est toujours
important de discuter avec ses pairs.
Donc on s’est réuni avec des équipes
qui travaillaient sur le cancer du côlon,
de la prostate, du col de l’utérus,
et qui travaillaient soit sur la salive,
l’air expiré, le sang, peu importe.
Et on a vu en effet qu’on avait
des questions communes
parce qu’il y avait plein de réponses
scientifiques non encore résolues
concernant l’odorologie canine.
Néanmoins, on s’est lancé
et on a fait cette étude clinique.
Et aujourd’hui, où en est-on ?
On l’a interrompue.
Pourquoi l’a-t-on interrompue ?
On avait des bons résultats :
les chiens trouvaient le cancer environ -
tous nos résultats ne sont pas sortis -
mais entre 65 et 70%,
ce qui est pas mal
mais complètement insuffisant
pour faire de la détection
d’une maladie aussi grave que le cancer.
Et très vite, ce qu’on a remarqué,
c’est qu’il y avait une variabilité.
Un jour, les chiens travaillaient bien,
un autre moins.
Quelquefois, cet exercice est
tellement difficile pour eux,
parce que l’odeur est extrêmement faible,
qu’ils se lassent, tout simplement.
Parce que si c’était aussi facile
que les drogues et les explosifs -
ça a une odeur forte, simple,
ce sont des matériaux inertes -
ou que des pathologies infectieuses ou
virales, qui vont beaucoup se disséminer,
ça serait le bonheur.
Mais là, on peut être dans des
seuils d’odeur extrêmement bas,
avec des signatures de l’odeur complexes.
On le voit parce qu’on progresse
en chimie dans notre projet,
qui s’appelle KDOG COV,
mais néanmoins on n’en est pas encore
à trouver la signature exacte du cancer.
Vous allez vous dire :
« Quoi ? L’aventure s’est terminée là ? »
Je pense que si
tous les chercheurs s’arrêtaient
quand ils n’ont pas tout à fait
les résultats qu’ils espéraient,
il n’y aurait plus beaucoup
de chercheurs sur Terre.
Quand on arrive sur ce type de situation,
il faut se dire deux choses.
Soit j’ai des chances que ça marche mieux,
je sais ce que je peux faire
pour essayer d’améliorer les choses.
Dans ce cas-là, évidemment,
même si c’est difficile,
il faut rebondir, il faut continuer.
Soit on se dit : « Je n’ai pas de piste,
mes résultats sont insuffisants. »
Dans ce cas-là, en effet,
il est sage d’arrêter
et de faire connaître
ses résultats négatifs
et les raisons de ces résultats négatifs.
Parce qu’en sciences, un résultat négatif
est un résultat intéressant
pour toute la communauté scientifique.
Dans le cadre de KDOG,
très vite, on a eu des pistes.
On a remarqué cette variabilité.
On se demandait comment
faciliter le travail des chiens.
On sait qu’ils y arrivent,
mais c’est tellement difficile
qu’il est variable et qu’il se lasse,
en sachant qu’il sera
toujours un peu variable
puisque c’est un être vivant.
Donc on s’est dit : « Peut-être que
nos compresses, ce n’est pas bien.
Peut-être que d’autres matériaux absorbent
et relarguent mieux les odeurs. »
De plus, quand on a commencé
notre étude clinique, il y a eu le Covid.
Je suis infirmière, donc ma priorité
à ce moment-là n’a pas été la recherche,
mais les patients.
Les bocaux dans lesquels il y avait
des compresses qu’on a conservées
sont restés plusieurs mois.
On s’est dit : « Mais finalement, on n’a
jamais travaillé sur la conservation.
À quel moment l’odeur est la plus forte ?
Là aussi, ça pourrait faciliter
le travail des chiens. »
On a vu aussi que c’était plus difficile
pour certains chiens que pour d’autres.
On s’est dit :
« Il n’y a pas eu de travail
sur le seuil jusqu’où
le chien peut descendre.
Et est-ce qu’il renifle bien tous les COV
ou certains COV mieux que d’autres ? »
Aujourd’hui, on fait ça.
On fait des travaux pour répondre
précisément, scientifiquement,
méthodiquement,
à chacune de ces questions,
pour qu’un jour notre équipe, ou d’autres,
réussissent à développer vraiment,
en clinique et en pratique,
le diagnostic du cancer
par les odeurs avec des chiens
ou peut-être avec un nez
ou une truffe électroniques.
En parallèle de tout ça, je continue
à faire mon métier, avoir des patients,
c’est mon moteur.
Vraiment, le plaisir à faire ce métier
d’infirmière est toujours intact.
Je pense que pour moi c’est important
parce que ça me permet de garder le cap
et de savoir pourquoi
et pour qui je cherche.
(Applaudissements)